how do you know if if a coin is a scam
or not
well
you can you can see a few things so you
know i hate to use the word scam because
a lot of these these are judgment calls
you gotta i kind of a court made me or a
jury may land either way but things that
would be red flags to look at would be
um you know is a bunch of the asset
owned by an insider or insiders um with
short vesting periods
um
you know
are
does the background of the founders like
they may have criminal records or if
they've perpetrated other frauds in the
past right
um there's a difference between
something which is
just a me too product it's like it
doesn't have anything interesting about
it and something that's an actual fraud
or outright scam and
um
you have to a lot of this data what's
cool about it is that it's now available
on chain you can look at like the
tokenomics behind it and see who owns
economics and are they yeah and are they
selling it you know
in
like inappropriately or are they pumping
it on like youtube and twitter and
making promises about hey the value of
this thing may be higher in the future
and like all those are just big big
no-no's that we would
um
you know we just don't want to go there
so
our whole thing is like we want we want
to enable the innovation in this space
but not allow anybody to
curtail the advancement of this industry
by like doing some kind of fraudulent
thing or get rich quick thing
you